[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So welcome,
everyone, and thank you
for coming to today's talk.
Today, as a member of the
IMIA Mental Health Conference
committee and one of
your well-being champs,
I'm delighted to
be able to welcome
Florence Servan-Schreiber
to Google France.
Florence, having
studied humanistic
psychology and sustainability
management in San Francisco.
She went on to train
in positive psychology
with the renowned Harvard
professor Tal Ben-Shahar.
She is the bestselling author
of "3 Kifs Par Jour" and "Power
Patate," and she joins us
today to discuss "Unleash Your
Superpowers."
Please put your hands
together for Florence.
[APPLAUSE]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Thank you very much.
[INAUDIBLE], you may want this.
So bonjour, hello.
My name is Florence.
Florence Servan-Schreiber.
I picked to do this talk in
English because I believe
most of you do speak English.
And most talks I
do are in French,
so I decided to do something
a little more difficult than I
usually do, since
we are going to be
unleashing our superpowers.
So why would we talk about
superpowers, possibly?
How many of you
here are familiar
with positive psychology?
OK.
So for the rest of us,
positive psychology
is not positive thinking.
Just so you relax
on that matter.
What is positive psychology?
Basically, about 20
years ago, a researcher
from University of
Pennsylvania, Marty Seligman,
realized that when we dealt
with research in psychology,
it always had to do with
mental health, of course,
but with mental diseases.
And basically, he was elected
at the head of the Psychology
Institute of the United States,
which basically brings together
researchers.
And Seligman said,
why don't we try
and see if we could think
research differently to come up
with a preventive psychology?
Because we all know
that, in health matters,
there are things that we
can do more of or less
of that will enable us to
live longer in better health.
But on a mental level,
are there things
that we can do more of or
less of that will enable us--
so what can it enable us to do?
Not so much avoid the hardships
of life, because the hardships
will be coming our way.
Maybe they have
already come your way.
But the good news is, they
are heading towards us.
So since they are
heading towards us,
to know how to get
back on our feet
in order to feel more power
to be able to get back
in our daily lives after
miserable things happen to us.
That's when he decides to
create a new area of research.
Positive psychology is
actually brings together
researchers from
different psychology labs
who work on three things--
behaviors, personalities,
and organizations that work.
It's also called the
science of happiness.
Have you heard of the
science of happiness?
OK.
Wonderful.
So this is what
positive psychology is.
So my job-- my day job--
I have a few jobs,
but my day job
is to actually be a
happiness teacher.
So what I do is look
at the research,
try everything before
I get anywhere to talk
or write about it.
And thanks for the author thing.
I have published
books, so maybe I
am the first author that
you are seeing here.
I don't know, maybe.
Anyway, before I write anything,
before I talk about anything,
I actually try it out.
And I guess that's how
I'm able to come, then,
and tell you what
we can possibly do.
Positive psychology
is information.
It's not therapy.
Once you know that there
are certain behaviors that
can lead us to feel
this way or that,
then you are completely
free to try it out.
So since this is
all about happiness,
let's start with happiness.
What is happiness?
Basically, maybe I'll
begin with what it is not.
Happiness is not the
opposite of unhappiness.
If you look at your lives,
whatever day goes by,
whatever month or
year goes by, you
will be swinging from
one state to the next.
Sometimes, you feel great.
Sometimes, you feel awful.
And maybe the day so far
has gone perfectly well.
None of us here is protected
from receiving a terrible text
message where your
world goes upside down.
None of us.
But on the other hand, we can
wake up feeling really grumpy,
and none of us is
protected from a [FRENCH]..
You know what [FRENCH] is.
Love at first sight.
We have no idea what's
going to happen.
The only thing that
we have to understand
is that we will be swinging
from one state to the other.
And the opposite of
happiness is apathy.
Apathy is when we are
stuck in the middle,
and we just don't
know where to go.
And the clinical version of
apathy is called depression.
And in that particular matter,
we need regular psychology
to cure us.
But when we're dealing
with flourishing,
when we're dealing with, how do
we enjoy the projects that we
work on?
How do we enjoy the
relationships that we are in?
How do we dilate inside of
our little envelope here?
This is a pretty
small space that we
each use on this planet.
Within that little
space, how can we
use up most of the space
that is ours, actually?
And that is what positive
psychology is about.
Let's expand inside who we are.
So I have a question for you.
Where does our ability
to be happy come from?
I'll be a little more specific.
Who among you believes that our
ability to be happy is genetic?
That it is pre-programmed.
Who thinks it is?
OK, who thinks it's not?
All right.
And who doesn't know?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: OK.
So this is one of the first
things that regular psychology,
one of the first
questions that they ask.
Where does our ability
to be happy come from?
Is it genetic?
So the first thing they have
to do is scratch their head.
How can we find that out?
And they realize there's
only one way to go.
They are going to have
to find identical twins.
And identical
twins are basically
one egg that has been
separated in two pieces.
So it's the same genetic code.
But we need these twins to
have been separated at birth,
adopted in different families.
And we prefer them to be
older than 40 years old,
so things have happened to them.
And these twins come in.
And the question is, now, to
measure their happiness level.
So how does one measure
a happiness level?
Basically, there's no software.
There's no blood test.
No saliva tests that can
tell us if you're happy.
The only way to measure
happiness is self-declarative--
knowing that you are the only
person to know how you feel.
So we ask you a
series of questions.
And you always have to answer
on a scale from 1 to 10.
So for example,
you can be asked,
how do you feel about
your current projects?
Or you can be asked,
how do you feel
when you look at your peers?
Or, how do you feel about
your childhood dreams?
We can also go through emotions.
How much joy do
you feel right now?
How much anger?
How much fear?
And so forth.
We sum it all up, and
we have an average.
That's your happiness score.
So the twins have very
different lifestyles.
They are asked all
these questions.
However, they come
up 90% of them
declare the exact same level
of happiness as their twin.
So the researchers
are very happy.
And they publish, and they
say, OK, ladies and gentlemen,
happiness is just like height.
It's genetic.
The talk is over.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE
SERVAN-SCHREIBER: OK, this
is before positive
psychology comes in.
So we lived with
that for a while.
And then these new
scientists come
in with a slightly
different approach
when it comes to happiness.
Basically, what they have
figured out is the following.
The question conditions
the response.
Which means that,
in if our lives,
we look for what's
wrong, we will
find what's wrong right away.
But if we start looking
for what is right,
then we will start
looking what is right,
and what is going
well in our lives.
So what they see are
the same results,
but they read them upside down.
And what they are
interested in are the 10%
of twins who have the exact same
genetic code as somebody else.
However, they are
happier or unhappier.
How is it possible?
So a woman named Sonja
Lyubomirsky works out
of UC Davis in California.
And in her lab, the
only question she asks
is, where does
happiness comes from?
She has met people who have
experienced all our wildest
dreams.
Winning at the lottery.
Getting an entire
makeover physically.
That type of crazy things
that we always think that
could possibly make us happier.
Anyway, she went through
a bunch, a bunch, a bunch
of situations and people.
And basically, she was
able to figure it out.
50% of our ability to
experience happiness
is actually pre-determined.
It comes from one of our
genes called the 5-HTT.
5-HTT swims up there
somewhere and is
responsible for manufacturing
all the neurotransmitters that
run up in our brains.
Dopamine, endorphins,
serotonin, oxytocin.
You know all these words?
Lots of "-in" words that are
basically all the substances
that our brain will actually
manufacture when we feel great.
And when we feel great,
it manufactures even more.
So the longer the 5-HTT, the
more of these neurotransmitters
our brain is able
to manufacture.
The shorter it is, the
drier it is up there.
So this is why there
are different types
of personalities.
And we all have people around
us for whom everything is fun.
Everything is cool.
Basically, it's probable that
they have a very long 5-HTT.
And then for the rest of us,
maybe it's a bit shorter,
and we don't really experience
things the same way.
But you know something?
It's exactly like height.
It is a lottery.
But for example, I belong to--
let's say, I'm a short person.
Well, I can tell the tall people
that, even at this altitude,
life is fine.
We are fine.
We will get used to
whatever our conditions are.
And that's the good
thing about humans.
We're great chameleons.
So that's half of it--
of our ability to be happy.
Now, what else do
we need to be happy?
So I'll just take orders.
What would you like?
We all want the same thing,
so you can just shout it out.
AUDIENCE: Love.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: Love.
Thank you.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Connections.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Connections.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Connections, yes.
AUDIENCE: Purpose.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Purpose, yeah.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Food.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: Food.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: Yeah.
Absolutely, food.
Certainly.
AUDIENCE: Health.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Health, yes.
To be in good health.
Of course.
AUDIENCE: Comfort.
FLORENCE
SERVAN-SCHREIBER: Comfort.
Little money, anybody?
Nah.
Really not.
Sunshine?
Just the regular stuff.
There's a lot of regular stuff
that actually makes us happy.
So if we talk about
regular stuff,
such as sunshine, comfort,
for example, even health.
The weather.
Everybody religiously
looks at the weather.
It's usually 53% accurate.
Not much more.
However, we still look at the
weather as an anticipation
to our happiness.
All those things
are circumstances.
And the outside
circumstances-- even our health
is a circumstance, actually.
The circumstances count
for 10% of our happiness.
But the thing is,
we all have a list--
it's not even one arm
long, it's two arms long--
of things that we would like to
change, or meet, or eradicate,
if it was legal.
Things where we
think, yes, if I could
change my life, if
things were different,
then I would be happier.
Maybe 10% happier.
But then of course,
we do sometimes
need to act on our
circumstances, and we can.
But what we cannot expect is
that changing the circumstances
will change everything
that happens.
So 50% is pre-programmed.
10% comes from the outside.
How much is left?
AUDIENCE: 40%.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
40%, yes.
You people can count.
Great.
So what do these
last 40% rely on?
They rely on our interpretation
of what happens in our lives.
And it has been determined
that the happiest people, when
something does not go the way
they had planned it, what they
will do is that, rather than
considering it as a setback,
they will actually feel that
they're already moving forward
in a different direction.
Meaning, when
something happens to us
that upsets us that we did
not plan, we do not want,
we will be frustrated.
We will be angry.
We will be pissed off.
We may even cry.
It's called being human.
But pretty quickly, these
people will say, OK.
I had planned to go
this way, I'm actually
going to have to go this way.
And they get back on their feet,
and they start moving again.
And basically, what
we have to remember
is that it is not so
much what happens to us,
but it is what we do
about what happens
to us that really matters.
So I know a little
bit about that.
I became interested
in positive psychology
and changed to
this new profession
because my previous job left me.
So in such a circumstance--
at least some of you
think it's funny.
I didn't think it was very
funny when it happened, exactly.
It's always a little--
lots of things.
Downsizing, and-- so
no, everything's fine,
but it is a little humiliating.
There's a lot of
stuff that happens
at that particular time.
But had it not
happened, I really
don't know why or how I would
have gone back to study--
had the time to have
simply gone back
and studied positive psychology
for real, which is what I did.
And I learned all
this material, and I
thought it was so
easy to implement,
and so interesting,
and so ongoing,
because the research
is constantly ongoing,
it's a very new science,
that I decided--
so in France, things are
sort of well-organized
when you get fired.
You know about that.
And I had a little
time on my hands.
So what I decided to
do was try everything.
So I tried everything.
I learned meditation.
You guys know about
meditation, right?
You know that meditation
can be learned.
You don't just sit
there and meditate.
It's actually a skill.
It's like the rest of the
things that we know how to do.
I exercised more.
To be honest, I
began exercising.
And I did write letters
to people in my life,
because when you do
write letters to people,
you are happier.
And then at the end of
this particular year--
I have a tendency
to forget things.
I didn't want to
forget this time.
So I decided to sit down
and write the story.
And when the book came
out here in France,
the book did very
well instantly,
so that was a surprise.
But I realized
something very simple.
That although we are very unique
individuals, there's something
we have all in common.
With more information,
we make better decisions.
And the more we know
about behaviors, the freer
we are to choose to
implement these behaviors
or to try things out.
And that's how I decided
to go on and keep talking
about this particular topic.
Then, as we say in French,
basically, [FRENCH]..
Basically, a bus ran me over.
Not literally.
But we will all be
run over by buses.
And in my case, what
happened is that I had
a very close and dear cousin.
His name was David
Servan-Schreiber.
Some of you may know his name.
And David was my age.
And David died.
He died from brain tumor.
He was a doctor, and as a
doctor, when he was diagnosed,
he was diagnosed when
he was 30 years old.
And he decided to look for ways
that he could fight cancer.
His doctors said,
just go on and live
the way you live your life.
And he said, no, I
don't believe that,
and I'm sure there's something
better that I can do.
So he began compulsing
all the research that
has been done about
fighting cancer cells that
weren't really promoted, and
basically completely changed
his lifestyle and gained 20
years of life expectancy.
Brain tumors usually win
the fight, and it did.
David was a psychiatrist,
and he had built a training
school for psychiatrists.
And that company was orphaned.
And one thing that I decided
to do one morning is I woke up,
and I thought, OK, I'm going to
buy this company from his kids,
and I'm going to
continue his work.
And that's when all my
little voices woke up.
So one little voice here
told me, Flo, let me just
remind you, you can't count.
Which is not untrue.
And then another voice
here said, you did already
start a company, remember?
And the company went broke.
Are you sure you want
to do that again?
And I said, OK, girls, thank
you very much for the advice,
but I'm going.
I'm going to do this.
And this was seven years ago.
I have no other
word to define what
has happened to
us professionally
than to say that
we have flourished.
You know what "flourished" is?
[FRENCH]
So how do you flourish
on a professional level?
What does it mean?
So it means, of course, that
all the jobs were saved,
and we have created more.
We've expanded.
It means that we've gone
beyond our objectives.
It means that we like
the way we contribute
to the area that is ours.
And it also means that we were
able to learn to work together.
Because there were people that
I had not chosen, and they
had not chosen me either.
However, it did work out.
So I began wondering,
how is it possible?
How can somebody very normal
like me-- so I know two things.
I was trained in English,
obviously, and in psychology.
But running a company?
Managing a team?
Not only did I have no
appetite, but no intuition
for that at all.
But it worked.
So that's when I began looking
at superpowers, obviously.
And I started to wonder if there
weren't within each one of us
very simple things
that we could actually
count on when the storm started
coming up, and coming at us.
So naturally, what did I do?
I turned to positive psychology.
And what this bunch
of researchers
did when they actually began
positive psychology is they
realized that there
was no universal list
of human qualities.
We did not know
what qualities were
to be found across the world,
and that we could actually
count on.
So they began looking,
and they read everything
that was published in
psychology, philosophy,
religions, and put
them all together.
And they came up with 24
common character strengths,
they called them.
Character strengths are
qualities, basically.
And so they had to make sure.
They had to verify that
these qualities actually
really existed when you
went out to meet people.
So they separated
in different teams,
and my favorite
team went to Africa.
And they go and visit
Maasai warriors.
Now, Maasai warriors
are people who
still hunt lions with pierces.
"Pierce," is that
how you say it?
AUDIENCE: Spears.
FLORENCE
SERVAN-SCHREIBER: Spears.
Spears.
With a spear.
And so they go to
the Maasai warrior.
And they say, OK, this is for
a study that we are handling.
Are you familiar with the
concept of leadership?
So the Maasai warrior
says, yes, I am.
Say, no, no, no.
Do you personally know people
who actually are leaders?
So the Maasai warrior
says, yes, I do.
No, no, no.
Do you know as many
men as women who
actually express leadership?
So the warrior says, yes, I do.
Says, no, no, but
one more question.
Would you like your children
to actually express leadership?
And he said, of course I want my
children to express leadership.
So they go, yeah, they
know about leadership.
It's a familiar trait.
And they did the same
thing with Eskimos.
Eskimo [FRENCH].
AUDIENCE: Fishermen.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Fishermen.
Thank you very much.
With Eskimos and so forth.
And they validated
these qualities.
So let's see what qualities
we have in this room.
May as well.
Who among you is funny?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: OK.
All right, that's not bad.
You know, when you walk in
a class of elementary school
children and you say,
OK, who is smart?
Everybody raises their hands.
So I'll ask it again.
Who among you is funny?
All right, OK, there you go.
Who among you has
a sense of justice?
Yes.
Very nice.
Who among you is perseverant?
Yeah.
OK.
Wonderful.
Little harder.
Who among you is honest?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: OK.
Most of you are more
honest than you think.
OK, let me just check.
Who's ever kissed anyone?
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
OK, this is a happiness class.
There are things that are
worth living for, you know?
Things that you
could actually try.
So these are very
common qualities.
And what is a superpower?
It's a very common quality,
except that it's yours.
So basically, how do you use it?
So the culture that I
come from, being French,
you have to know, if you're
not from this country,
that talking about your
qualities just never happens.
It's not something we do.
It's rude.
It's pretentious.
It's absolutely not
something we ever do.
So when we do come up
with a list like that,
it's very useful,
because all of a sudden,
there's something
a little objective.
Because actually, what
you do is you go online
and you answer a
bunch of questions.
And at the end of
the questionnaire,
you are given the
answers that tell you,
OK, among the 24 universal
character strengths,
this is how yours are organized.
And then you know how it works.
Why is it useful?
I'll give you an example.
When I decided to
write this book,
I had no idea how
you write a book.
So I actually went and
asked people, senior people
who had written books.
They all came up with the
different ways that they do it.
But one thing came
back systematically.
All of them told me,
you sit down at 8:00 AM,
and you do not get
up until 12:00.
So I sat down at 8:00 AM.
And I had the
title of the book--
"3 Kifs Par Jour."
That I knew.
Tsh.
9 o'clock.
I'm sitting down.
10 o'clock.
11 o'clock.
Balance it out.
11:30.
12 o'clock.
And by 12 o'clock, I feel like
a pile of dust under my desk.
And I say to myself,
how do you expect
to write a book considering you
can't even stay on your chair,
basically?
And I did tell you earlier, I
think that I forget everything.
One thing that I had
forgotten when I actually
studied positive
psychology-- of course
I answered this questionnaire.
It's one of the basic
things that you do.
And there is a quality that
a lot of you here have.
And you have to
know that I'm very
impressed by how many of
you have this quality, which
is called perseverance.
Perseverance is the ability
to start something and take it
all the way until it's done.
When I answer the questionnaire,
out of the 24 strengths,
my 24th strength
is perseverance.
Which means that, in
this life, I will never
experience perseverance.
And it absolutely
does not matter.
And what we have
to understand is
that, if we do want
to take on challenges,
to have interesting
relationships with people,
to be excited about the projects
that we're actually running,
and enjoy doing
what we're doing,
we have to honor the strengths
that come to us naturally.
So in my case, I'll give
you my first top five.
The number one is curiosity.
Number two is creativity.
Number three is the ability
to love, and be loved.
Meaning that people
matter a lot to me.
Number four, I did not even
know it was a strength.
It's called
recognition of beauty.
It means that I'm very
sensitive to beauty around me,
but also to a job well done.
And then number
four is called zest.
Joie de vivre.
How do you write a
book with these things?
Basically, the way
it works is that I
do sit down at 8 o'clock,
just like the perseverance.
My brain is fresher, yes.
But I do exactly what I can.
And when I can't take
it anymore, I do get up
and I go in the room
next door, and it so
happens to be the kitchen.
And with my fingers, my creative
fingers who cannot just do
intellectual stuff, I will
either cook something or make
myself a cup of tea.
It doesn't matter.
I need to use my
fingers differently.
I come back.
I sit down.
And when I get stuck
again, I'll probably
grab a pen and start
drawing a star or whatever,
because I'm thinking already
about the cover of the book.
And it matters to me as much
as what's inside the book.
And then I get back to work.
And I live in Paris.
When I get stuck again--
I even live in
this neighborhood.
You may see me walking around.
When I get stuck again,
what I do is I go outside.
And I need to see, I need to
count buses, and [FRENCH],,
and whatever there is,
because my curiosity needs
to be fed every day.
And on the way back,
I will probably
call somebody, and
have a conversation
with a live person.
And once I understood that
and honored that, not only
was I able to hand my book
in with the 24 hours ahead
of time, but most
importantly, I began
enjoying what I was doing.
And what we each and every
one of us has to remember
is that we are
completely unique.
We are a completely unique
composition of these qualities.
Statistically, it's
impossible to have somebody
in this room who has the
same design of qualities
than you have.
And probably, if you are stuck
in anything in your life--
whether it's a project that's
difficult, or communicating
with your kids, communicating
with your lover, whatever
it is--
you are probably not
using your top qualities.
And you are probably using the
ones that are in the middle,
or maybe the worst
part is in the bottom.
The French school system
is very perseverant.
I was a very miserable
student in school.
But now that I can design my
own line of work, and the way
I do it, and however
I want to do it,
of course there's practically
no limit to where you can go
once you start respecting that.
So when I was looking
for superpowers,
I also began wondering
if there weren't
things that were a little
more common to everybody,
not as singular as the
character strengths.
And I ran into something very
interesting called the others.
Other people.
I don't know if you've
heard the fact that we
are social creatures,
meaning that we
are very interdependent.
So if people look at
you with admiration,
you will feel admirable.
You say that?
If people look at
you with criticism,
you're actually going to
feel terrible about yourself.
That's how it works.
We are that sensitive
to other people.
And there's one great study--
you probably heard about this
study already--
where researchers
come into classrooms
where children are between
eight and nine years old.
And they tell the teacher, we
came up with a questionnaire
to determine if you have
high-potential students
in your class.
OK.
So the kids answer
the questionnaires.
They have no idea why they
are answering these questions.
So they answer everything.
Then the researchers
gather all the tests,
and they thank everybody,
and they leave.
They get to their lab, and
they throw everything out.
They come back three
weeks later and say,
we have looked through
every single test,
which is completely untrue.
We have looked
through the tests,
and we have found some
high-potential students
in your class.
Would you like to
know who they are?
Of course, the teacher says yes.
They don't even go
and see the kids.
They ask for a list.
And randomly,
completely randomly,
they point to three kids.
She's one, she's one, he's one.
Those kids, that
particular year,
made tremendous
progress compared
to their other classmates,
and later on went
for longer studies.
Why?
Because for one year, somebody
looked at them thinking,
you are a high-potential person.
And I can hear you.
So the first thing that comes
through your mind is, OK.
People should have
looked at me differently.
Right?
That explains it all.
OK.
And if by any chance, you
have children of your own,
you are completely panicked.
It is still time.
But the question that
I would rather ask you
is, how do you look at people?
Because I know how
the French people
look at other French people.
But how do you look at people?
Do you look at people wondering,
woof, look at this guy.
Or do you wonder, what are
this person's qualities?
What are their superpowers?
How do I work with
these superpowers?
Because in an ideal
world, parents
would look at their
children like this.
Managers would look at
their employees like this.
Teachers would look at
their students like this.
But then there's real life.
I can testify.
When my oldest son, Arthur,
was 21, he came to me
and he said, OK.
Mom, I'm going to Australia.
So I'm trained in
positive psychology.
The whole deal.
And what comes out of my mouth
is, don't even think about it.
That's real life.
So what we need to do
about this information--
just remember that
here, what matters
are the 40% that we
actually have control over.
I have no control
over what you're
right now thinking about me.
None.
And I never will.
That, I cannot control.
I have no influence on.
But this is what
I have control on.
I can decide who I talk
to, and about what.
Meaning, when
Arthur comes to me,
because his plan is
to go to Australia
and I'm unable to encourage
him, then his mission
is to go to somebody else who
sees him bigger than he is.
We all have in our lives
people that we actually
turn to when we want to
do something difficult
and we say, OK, this
is what I want to do.
And then some people
will say, yeah, you know?
I don't know.
"I just wouldn't want you to be
disappointed" type of reaction.
You don't go back
to these people.
And then there's another type of
person where you actually say,
I do want to go to Australia,
who would say, yes, absolutely.
You have to go to Australia.
We must know, in our lives,
who sees us bigger than we are.
We can organize
our support system.
We can organize the mirror
that is actually held
in front of us, because this
is how we'll push forward.
So let me finish with 10
happiness tips, if you want.
Scientifically proven, OK?
All of them.
Number one.
Savor more.
[FRENCH]
You know what savoring is?
We spend so much time being
already in the "whatever's
coming next," or still
in what came before,
that most of the time, we
just forget to be here,
doing what we're
doing right now.
So one way to
savor is very easy.
When we are actually somewhere
and happy about where we are,
we turn to the person next to us
and we just say, this is great.
That's savoring.
Number two.
Stop comparing
yourselves to others.
Not only are you
fine the way you are,
but it is the way you are
that we need you to be.
Because that is when
you are the most
singular, the most attractive,
the most competent,
the most unique.
There is absolutely nobody
else out there like you.
And your only job is to live
with this particular person.
So that's all you have to do.
And when I say stop comparing
yourselves to others,
we usually compare
ourselves socially.
So when it comes to happiness--
this is the next tip--
think less about money.
All the economists have
looked at the situation.
What is the link between
wealth and happiness?
So of course, if
you are destitute--
if you are a refugee,
for example--
it will make a lot of
difference, necessarily.
But in this
particular room right
here, it probably will
not make a difference.
Accumulating goods has
never made anybody happy.
There is one exception.
Shoes.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Next tip.
AUDIENCE: Scientifically proven?
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Scientifically proven,
the shoes.
And we're waiting for
the handbag research.
It's on its way.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Next tip.
There are three
components to happiness.
One is pleasure, number
two is engagement,
and number three is meaning.
Which means that
we need all three.
Pleasure is not enough.
Pleasure is great.
Engagement means we
need to be part of.
Parts of groups,
part of projects.
There's something very
active about being happy.
It's not just watching nature.
Watching nature is
part of happiness,
but there's something
very productive.
But it's not enough.
We also need to have meaning.
Why am I doing all this?
What does it bring to me?
What am I bringing to the world?
That's very important.
So there too.
If you think your
life these days is not
exactly how you want it to be,
do you have enough pleasure?
Sometimes we're changing the
world and we're super busy.
But is it pleasant
enough for us?
And then sometimes, we're
partying like wild people,
and we're completely engaged.
But is there any meaning to us?
So it's a way of
adding what you need,
or just making sure
everything is there.
Following tip has been
proven by Maria Montessori.
She works with children.
She worked with children.
We're big children.
We're never as happy as when we
have decided what we're doing.
So the best thing to do is
to take initiatives and say,
this is what I want to do.
This is what I want to work on.
This is what I want to watch.
This is what I want to eat.
The more we express
our needs and desires,
the easier it is to get there.
Number six, cherish
your families.
Cherish your friends.
Cherish your colleagues.
Why do I say this?
Because the longest happiness
study began in 1938.
It was decided to follow
the entire class of Harvard
University.
All men at the time.
And they all agreed to answer
a questionnaire every year
about their life conditions
and their happiness levels.
After 30 years, the
researcher retires.
So the younger researchers come
in and say, so now, come on,
you've been looking at these
people for 30 years now.
Can you tell us anything
about happiness?
Have you noticed any difference
between the ones that are happy
and the ones that aren't?
And he said, yeah.
Absolutely.
I know everything
about these guys.
I know where they live.
I know how much they make.
I know if they are alcoholic,
if they're depressed.
I know if their mother was nice
to them when they were kids.
And the only thing
that matters is love.
And when he says love, it's not
just romantic or family ties,
but it is the nature
of relationships
that we actually
have in our lives.
Following tip, "trois kifs"--
three good things.
Count your blessings.
A blessing is something
that you have the urge
to say thank you for.
Usually, it's called gratitude.
It usually starts with
pleasure, but pleasures just
fly out the door.
Unless we stop just for a
second and think to ourselves,
for that, thank you.
When we do that, we can
gain up to seven years
of life expectancy.
There is a
physiological response
to gratitude that will
make us live longer
and in better health.
The following tip,
exercise more.
I told you.
And I'm just talking
about mood exercise.
I'm not talking about
physical health.
Just the brain health.
We were not designed to order
sushi and ride escalators.
That was just not the plan.
So our bodies are
completely underused.
We need to use the body in
order to irrigate the brain.
So it's three times, 30
minutes of aerobic anything
that you want to do.
When you live in Paris, usually
you walk around, so it's good.
You're there already.
Next before last.
When you talk about
happiness, giving is always
superior to receiving.
Which means that every time we
do something for somebody else,
we get a little
shower of dopamine
up in the brain that makes
us feel absolutely wonderful.
And then the last tip--
this one is physiological.
This one will work with
anybody, whomever you are.
When you need to feel
better, right in a moment,
in an instant, there's
only one thing to do.
Smile.
And when I say smile,
it's not smile.
But when all the muscles
in the face are engaged,
it's impossible to
experience dark thoughts.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Thank you so much.
Thank you very much, Florence.
That was a very insightful,
very entertaining talk.
Thank you.
I know you've got a short
window just for some Q&A.
So can I open it
up to the audience?
Are there any questions
following this talk?
Have any questions for Florence?
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
So questions
can be your own stories.
When it comes to happiness,
positive psychology
is just about observing
regular people.
So why is it useful?
Because we're so
busy with our lives
that we only do the
things, we do them.
And sometimes, just hearing how
other people actually do things
gives us more ideas.
So how can I say?
Your experience has as
much value as anything
that I have said so far.
What is this yellow box?
SPEAKER 2: It is a microphone.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Oh, it's a microphone!
SPEAKER 2: It can be thrown.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
So there's a running--
oh, it can be thrown, OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just have a question.
Don't you think that happiness
is linked to expectations?
The less you expect, then
the more happy you are?
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
[CHUCKLING]
Yeah.
Well, sometimes it's
also fun to expect things
that actually happen, you know?
There's that too.
How can we put it this way?
Maybe expectations are [FRENCH],,
or can hinder happiness.
Yes, there is a link.
But it's also great
to have expectations.
For example, when
people actually buy
tickets to the lottery--
so the worst thing
that can happen to you
is win the lottery, because
then you're in huge trouble.
Mentally, it is a big challenge
to actually win a lottery.
But buying the ticket is
the instant of expectations.
And the reason so many people
buy these tickets knowing
that they will
never win anything
is just for the
thrill of imagining
what you would do
if you actually
did win all that money.
So anticipation, rather
than expectations,
is a great feeling.
And that's another
tip I can give you--
but you know that already--
is to have things in your
life that you actually
anticipate that are coming
that are not there yet.
Sometimes we say
here in-- at least
in France-- that the
best part about love
is walking up the stairs, right?
That's anticipation.
SPEAKER 2: We have another
question just over there.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So where does
culture come in on this?
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
So culture is very present,
but the brain structure
remains the same.
I mean, you are probably all
very multi-cultured here.
And whoever has been
raised in France
and travels to
the United States,
for example, realizes it's
a very different culture.
Because, for example, when
it comes to happiness--
and I don't want to generalize,
because each individual is,
of course, very unique.
But it's true that when you do
get to sunny California, which
has been my case
many times, people
are by default
positive about what can
happen, about a possibility.
Whereas when you come
back to Paris, by default,
we are against
whatever is happening.
That's the basis.
Because if we are against,
then it's much chicer.
It's [FRENCH].
It is.
Because we believe
that because we
come from such an
intellectual background, yes?
We believe that if we
mark our opposition,
it shows that we have
thought about it.
That we're smarter.
So culture is huge.
But inside, the mechanisms
are the same ones.
So we have access.
Even us in Paris, we do
have access to happiness.
AUDIENCE: [CHUCKLING]
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
It's possible.
AUDIENCE: Do you mind if I
ask you a personal question?
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: Try.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So yesterday was
International Day of Girls,
and I would be very curious
to know what kind of girl
you were, and what was your
approach with happiness.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
As a child?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: OK.
Even as a grownup, I'm a
very worried, pessimistic
individual, which is the reason
that I found so much value
in what I'm bringing you today.
I am not like that.
I mean, I am
completely like that.
But it comes.
It comes from fear.
It comes from just--
yeah, I guess fear is probably
the best word to qualify it.
Because I am an
anxious person, I
need to do things that make
life easier for myself,
if that answers your question.
But I did have fun too.
But yes, it does
it does come from--
the thing about positive
psychology-- and you know that.
You all know that.
When life is all right,
we need none of this.
We need none of
this information.
We just go on leading our lives.
That's what we do.
But when all of a sudden,
things get a little darker,
and things get a little
more complicated,
then it's very useful to know
that we have these resources.
I'll give you an example.
When it comes to gratitude--
my favorite absolute topic
is gratitude.
When the researchers
decided to look
at what the impact of gratitude
can be, one thing they did--
they actually found out.
They decided to go, and
five years after 9/11,
go meet with the
victims' families.
They wanted to understand
what people had done
in order to get back into life.
How did they get back into life?
And they found
different families.
Some were not back into life.
Some were already
back into life.
And one of the differences
between the two
is that the ones who
were back in motion
were people who, before
9/11, in their everyday life,
were expressing gratitude,
and feeling gratitude.
So this is why, when we talk
about preventive psychology,
the more in our
everyday OK lives
we can practice to use
gratitude, for example,
and to feel grateful, when
the storm hits the fan,
we will have more training.
It will be easier for us to
actually press on the button.
So this is what is so precious
about all this information.
Once again, it's just to train.
The default mode of our brain
is to first perceive negativity.
Whatever is wrong,
smells awful, is scary,
has much more impact on us
than what is nice, and good,
because we consider it regular.
It's a safety measure.
It's very useful for danger.
But, however, for the day
we really get in trouble,
it is definitely worth,
while things are OK,
to start training with all
those little exercises.
And optimism is one
that I really work on.
I work on it.
It's like an exercise that I do.
It's like a physical exercise
that I do on my brain,
or else I just think
the world is over.
And every time one of
my kids had a fever,
I thought he was going to die.
So this is why we need to train.
We all know what our levels are.
We know what our buttons are.
We know what our fears are.
And we can help those fears.
That's the good news.
SPEAKER 2: Two more people.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER: Do
you ever throw it, actually?
AUDIENCE: I will.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Have people thrown it?
Op!
Woo!
OK.
SPEAKER 2: That's
throwing it, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Here you go.
AUDIENCE: Merci.
I like it very much
when you shared
the story of your son
coming to you saying
he was going to Australia and
you were not really supportive.
But what happens when you
actually try to be supportive
but just think that someone
has a very bad idea?
How do you manage that?
Can I just say, go to someone
who is going to be supportive,
because you really,
truly, sincerely
think that it's not a
good thing for them.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Well, of course.
That's called a debate.
And you can get
into a conversation.
In that case, it
was a good idea,
so I had nothing more to say.
But of course, you debate
your ideas, necessarily.
And people do have
terrible ideas.
And when you're a
mother, wait till you
see what ideas your kids have.
They have terrible ideas.
AUDIENCE: I can see already.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to ask you a question.
So if you do some readings,
or if you go to such talks,
and you feel really
inspired, but you
have someone that
you really love,
and you see that they're stuck,
and they're in an unhappy
place, what can
you do to help them
without coaching them
or sounding like you're
giving them instructions?
I would be really interested.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
That's a real life situation.
We cannot change other people.
That's the first thing we
have to admit and agree to.
We cannot change other people.
The only thing we can do
is do what we believe in.
Because if you start
coaching somebody,
they will maybe resist it.
The only thing you can
do, if you strongly
believe in being
a different way,
is to actually be that way.
And there's something that ends
up being contagious, or not.
Not everybody will follow you.
But at least that's the
only thing you can try.
But going to somebody saying--
a lot of people come to
my talks and say, ugh.
I have to tell my
mother-in-law about you,
because she really
needs your talk.
That type of thing
doesn't really happen.
The mother-in-law will
not make progress,
because it's not her motivation.
We do care for others.
We would like them
to be more positive.
But you also have to
understand something, is that--
I have an aunt like that.
She adores terrible news,
but adores to a point
that it's insane.
We have to respect that too.
Some people feed on atrocities.
And it actually does--
it gives more energy
to their lives.
So I will never change her.
The only thing I can do, if I'm
around her, is just be the way
I think that I want to be,
or that I think life can be.
And sometimes miracles happen.
People get better.
And then that's another thing.
Sometimes people need help.
It depends.
Sometimes people need
psychological help.
And then we're not talking
about positive psychology,
but this is a mental
health conference today.
And mental health is a
whole different story.
Sometimes, we
actually need help,
and we have to be
able to get it.
SPEAKER 2: OK, thank
you very much, Florence.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Thank you very much.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
FLORENCE SERVAN-SCHREIBER:
Take care.
[APPLAUSE]